plein merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
le feuilleton de la déchéance de
nationalité continue le président et
revoit s'est envoyé en mission d'urgence
pour essayer de recoller les morceaux
dans la majorité on ne sait où on en est
déchéance de nationalité déchéance de
citoyenneté indignité nationale la garde
des sceaux est remplacé par le premier
ministre lui-même pour défendre le texte
au parlement que d'atermoiements que
deux yoyo les français eux attendent de
se sentir en sécurité
personne vraiment personne l'a contraint
le président de la république à
s'exprimer comme il l'a fait à
versailles
n'at-il donc aucune autorité et surtout
surtout beaucoup d'autres sujets sont en
attente et ne sont pas prises en compte
les agriculteurs français lancent un cri
d'appel crise du porc crise du lait
crise de l'élevage crise légumière
désormais crise pour tous si j'ose dire
la crise fait des ravages dans nos
campagnes nos paysans n'en peuvent plus
que fait-on pour eux les pme les
artisans les commerçants
tous ont de lourdes charges les normes
les ralentissent leur et le rsi ne les
comprend pas toujours les marchés sont
atones
que fait-on pour eux les salariés sont
inquiets pour leurs entreprises pour
leur emploi que fait-on pour e24 sur 28
pays en europe ont commencé à inverser
la courbe du chômage
quatre n'ont toujours pas réussi dont la
france et que proposez-vous un plan d'un
milliard d'euros pour retirer sans doute
cinq cent mille chômeurs de nos
statistiques ce n'est franchement pas à
la hauteur
même la ministre de l'emploi se prend
les pieds dans le tapis de la courbe du
chômage et se contredit à deux ou trois
jours d'intervalle
alors oui monsieur le premier ministre
au lieu de colmater les brèches sur la
révision de la constitution dans la
majorité
quand allez-vous mettre toutes vos
forces au delà de ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui dans la bataille de
l'économie dans la bataille de l'emploi
dans la bataille du pouvoir d'achat pour
prête vraiment au service de la france
et des français
la parole est au premier ministre manuel
valls oui monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés mais c'est le
cas cette semaine je réponds à la
dernière question qui sans avoir
l'outrance de celle d'hier mélange mais
avec votre propre cohérence et je la
respecte toute une série de sujets
chacun peut parler vous inquiétez pas
monsieur le président mais celui qu'on
entend surtout c'est vous mais rarement
monsieur jacob sur le fond et sur les
propositions
c'est beau je réponds à monsieur
gosselin et je répondrai à la première
partie je répondrai à la première partie
de votre de votre question parce que
précisément blé vous plus je pense
ramener à l'essentiel et l'essentiel
c'est la situation de notre pays
confrontés d'abord à une menace
terroriste sans précédent à des attaques
bien sûr au mois de janvier est au moins
de novembre dernier et c'est mon cas
c'est bien sûr pour chacun d'entre vous
la même chose nous devons nous souvenir
d'abord de ses victimes et de ses
centaines de blessés et de leurs
milliers de proches parce que le pays
est encore sous le choc
sur le coup et sous la sidération de ces
événements le président l'a public le 16
novembre puisque vous interrogez a voulu
après ces événements trois jours après
les événements du 13 novembre
cette attaque terrible faire en sorte
que la nation se rassemblent à travers
la réunion du parlement en congrès à
versailles
et sache personne ne doit l'oublier ni
le discours ni l'engagement c'est à dire
des moyens supplémentaires comme au mois
de février pour nos forces de sécurité
armée police gendarmerie pour la justice
mais il a souhaité aussi à travers la
réforme constitutionnelle non seulement
à soir dans notre droit fondamental
l'état d'urgence mais faire en sorte que
précisément nous recherchions l'unité et
le rassemblement pas seulement des
responsables politiques et des français
dans un moment
où nous dans un moment où tout pouvait
basculer et ma tâche et notre tâche
ceux qui aujourd'hui et c'est une belle
responsabilité ont la responsabilité du
gouvernement de la france c'est de faire
en sorte que cette union est ce
rassemblement sur ce sujet majeur soit
en permanence assurée et ce poids de
responsabilité il est évidemment sur les
épaules du gouvernement mais sur les
épaules de chaque parlementaire
d'autant plus que les mots que nous
avons décrit les uns et les autres il y
a d'ailleurs tout juste un an dans cette
enceinte sur ce qui se passe dans un
salon de nos quartiers sur le racisme
sur le rejet de l'eau sur un mal profond
qui dit d'ailleurs tout le reste
l'antisémitisme le mini l'intérieur
répondait hier à une question d'un
parlementaire sur cette agression
insoutenable à marseille sur la montée
de l'antisémitisme qui viennent
malheureusement le très loin celui de
l'extrême droite qu'on le retrouve sur
les réseaux sociaux celui de dieudonné
de soral celui d'une partie
malheureusement de l'extrême gauche qui
sait perthus sur ces questions là ça
nous oblige les uns les autres monsieur
le député à être vous dit à la hauteur
de la situation sur tous les domaines
c'est vrai bien sûr
et d'abord sur la sécurité c'est vrai
dans la manière de lutter contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme dans la volonté
de rassembler les français
mais c'est vrai aussi sur tous les
autres sujets c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement d'agir c'est votre
responsabilité de proposer ou de
critiquer d'agir mais la seule chose et
j'en termine c'est de faire en sorte
mais je ne doute pas de vos réactions
dans quelques secondes et notamment
celle de votre président de groupe c'est
de le faire avec esprit de
responsabilité
c'est en nous et vous voyez vous êtes
tombé dans le panneau c'est en nous
écoutant c'est en essayant d'avancer
c'est de faire en sorte en sorte que les
français qui nous regardent qui nous
regardent se disent que leurs
responsables politiques sont à la
hauteur
je me dis très modestement et avec mes
excuses monsieur le président de
l'assemblée nationale
mais je suis sûr que vous partagez que
que ceux qui regardent les questions au
gouvernement se disent parfois que les
uns et les autres ne sont pas à la
responsabilité justement attendu par les
français est bien le gouvernement
s'élèvent sur tous les sujets vous avez
hockey à la responsabilité et la jirs
pour obtenir des résultats parce que
c'est ce que les français nous demandent
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
séance de questions